yooz est sérieux c'est bien ce nouvel
épisode du coup de fil un air pur russie
ue des fois je parte en t-shirt avec une
référence à flash et je suis ici à vous
parler de philosophie et froid vous ça
vous intéresse toutes ces réponses se
trouvent dans l'habitude de vainqueur le
le fait de porter ce t-shirt ou ma
manière de parler mes goûts mes avis
tout ça c'est ce qui va me rendre unique
en tant qu'être humain et je dirais même
plus en tant qu'être social serre par
rapport à la société et aux relations
avec les autres et dur toutes ces choses
là comme âgées seules avec les mains
c'est des choses que j'ai acquises
durant ma socialisation et bien ensemble
de ces éléments ce que pierre bourdieu
va appeler l'habitus pierre bourdieu
c'est un sociologue français né en 1930
est mort en 2003 à sa engagées et pas
seulement sociologue puisqu'ils
s'étaient investis par exemple dans
l'indépendance de l'algérie ou le
soutien aux sans-papiers
il a aussi écrit énormément de livres
sur la sociologie tellement quand même
sortir un sur le foot
celui-ci ça s'appelle les enjeux du
football il était au mont liban pour
voir la finale de 98 et ça ça fait
plaisir
si vous n'étiez pas encore nés en 98
c'est pas grave hein vous vivrez plein
d'autres coûts et d'ailleurs tous ces
trucs cool que vous vivrez ou faire
évoluer et vous fassiez d'une certaine
manière
une façon d'être votre habitus est ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que cet
habitus il va se faire avec nos
expériences et donc aussi à l'aide de ce
qui nous entoure
ça commence pendant l'enfance et
l'adolescence ce qu'on appelle la
socialisation primaires c'est la famille
l'école
en fait c'est toute la première se faire
dans laquelle on va évoluer et avoir une
autre éducation
par exemple grâce au langage et pas
juste les mots aussi le corps un enfant
va apprendre à dire merci il va
apprendre comment le dire mais va aussi
apprendre à le dire par la gestuelle il
va apprendre à exprimer d'autres choses
comme ce qui veut manger mais aussi le
sourire ou la grimace tout ça ça va
construire l'enfant et cette
construction continue à l'âge adulte
c'est la socialisation secondaire donc
du coup vous avez appris votre langage
avec vos potes
ouais et votre manière de bouger dans
une école de danse contemporaine c'est
ça mais du coup vous n'êtes pas trop
schizophrène schizo quoi toi mon gars je
t'éclate org
donc c'est pour ça qu'un enfant né dans
une classe ouvrière il n'aura pas la
même éducation qu'un enfant né dans un
milieu très aisé
tu as deux rocks et behra pas pareil
qu'un chanteur de reggae un trader
n'utilisera pas le même langage qu'un
peintre sauf son expression sont mais
les pinceaux parce que c'est une façon
qui est largement utilisé du coup ça
dépasse le cadre de 2,4
ça dépasse le jargon du métier de
peintre je n'ai pas besoin de pinceau
pour cent et les pinceaux précision vous
avec des individus placés dans des
conditions similaires ont sensiblement
la même vision de la situation la même
notion de ce qu'on a le droit de faire
ou non les mêmes loisirs façon de
s'habiller ou de se comporter leur
habitus est très proche car ils ont
suivi des étapes de socialisation qui
sont elles aussi très proche
par contre c'est pas parce qu'on est
dans un même groupe social que nos
habitudes sont totalement identique
chaque personne est confrontée dans sa
vie à des expériences sociales
différentes
par exemple dans un groupe de potes on
aura tendance à vouloir aller voir le
même film mais on pensera pas tous
forcément la même chose de ce film
l'habitus ne déclenche pas
automatiquement des conduites identique
mais plutôt des tendances à certaines
conduites et heureusement sinon on
serait tous pareil parce que l'habitus
au final c'est ce qui façonne notre
identité nos goûts notre vision des
choses
notre manière de parler c'est des choses
avec lesquelles on se définit vous aimez
bien le thé vert
voilà vous aimez bien call of duty et
est ce que vous aimez bien djoloff
fustigé ce couvre-chef mec tu m'avais
pas faire partie du groupe social et
casquette rouge donc l'habitude c'est
nul très important c'est comme ça qu'on
va se définir mais c'est aussi comme ça
qu'on va se définir par rapport aux
autres et va nous donner notre place
dans la société
puisque avec lui on va faire partie d'un
groupe donné qui sera plus souvent
séparés des autres groupes
ça c'est ce qu'on vient de voir mais
peut-être encore plus important c'est
qu'un certain habitus aura tendance à
entraîner un certain habitus aujourd'hui
nous dit que l'habitude ce cd structure
structure est prédisposé à fonctionner
comme des structures structurants
structure structure et on l'a vu un
s'est structuré par notre construction
sociale mais aussi une structure
structurantes
c'est à dire que notre habitus ne sera
plus une conséquence ce sera aussi une
cause si vous retrouvez face et avec de
zombies par exemple vous pourrez pas
reproduire des mécanismes de penser
identiques à ceux qui sont à notre
habitus parce que c'est une situation à
laquelle vous n'avez jamais fait face et
vous n'avez pas été construit avec ça je
bosse éclater les ongles toi aussi là
bas
par contre tout ce que vous allez faire
à partir de l'instant où vous êtes dans
cette nouvelle situation
ça découle de vos expériences passées
les cédantes habitus que vous allez
prendre les codes sociaux que vous allez
adapter à cette nouvelle situation
structure structure ans je vous
laisserai pas les connexions avec le
déterminisme de spinoza
tout ça tout ça part on est une question
qui se pose est ce que cette structure
de mon habitude je vais la garder toute
ma vie pour bon dieu oui c'est ce qu'il
appelle lester résis de l'habitus
hystérésis pas hystérie et l'utilisent
exemple de dole crottés don quichotte un
portrait ce concept don quichotte c'est
un chevalier il a le mode de pensée d'un
chevalier le comportement le langage
l'attitude un chevalier sauf que c'est
un monde où il n'y a plus de chevalerie
donc il est inadapté à l'environnement
dans lequel ils se trouvent mais son
habitude est si fort qui va pas se
résigner et les tellement à fond qui va
s'attaquer au moulin à vent qui prend
pour de grands tyrans et globalement
c'est pour ça que les évolutions de nos
moeurs sont si difficiles parce que
certains habitus continue de perdurer
à une époque où ils perdent leur sens en
tout cas voilà ma façon d'être évolue
plutôt je suis assez content j'ai même
pas fait de jeu de mot avec par exemple
bourdieu et son habite prend l'habitude
de passer le coup de fil à un malus est
abonné à cyrus se le fait un gros bonus
j'espère que cette plus je vous envoie
du love et de la puce
[Musique]
la mecque